new york stolz schön faszinierend die
vielleicht legendärsten stadt der welt
aber auch hektisch und chaotisch wir
begleiteten vor eineinhalb jahren fünf
schweizerinnen und schweizer die den
sprung über den großen teich gewagt
haben
jetzt kehren wir zurück
was ist aus danielas bratwurst business
geworden wie hat sich das leben der
anderen war new yorker verändert und
haben sie neue pläne
[Musik]
daniela fischer superman ist auf
erfolgskurs vor eineinhalb jahren setzte
sie sich zum ziel ihres star wurst nebst
dem street food market auch in
geschäften zu verkaufen sie hat es
geschafft seit einem jahr beliefert
brooklyn kitchen mit ihren bratwürsten
15 dollar 99 kosten für stück ein
luxusprodukt
alle zwei wochen beliefert sie drei
spezialitätengeschäft hin brooklyn
[Musik]
das ist viel arbeit und sie überhaupt
nicht glamorous und in die höhe und für
die
1000 vista verkauft sie durchschnittlich
pro monat gerade genug um die kosten zu
decken
[Musik]
green point to clean
ehemals wohnquartier polnischer
einwanderer zieht es heute junge
familien künstler und hipster an
möbel designer patrick wieder zog vor
eineinhalb jahren neu in diese werkstatt
ein
[Musik]
für ihn war es wichtig der hektik new
yorks ein wenig zu entfliehen
ja sie haben
es geschafft und
konturen zu machen
dort zum dank
auch eine ecke für interessierte kunden
hat er geschaffen
patrick will sein netzwerk vergrößern
[Musik]
so einfach die neue sachen zeitlich oder
sachen nicht machen dafür zuständige
20 galerien zusammen schlafen hinlegen
und die anderen new york so ein
furniture showroom gallery sich sehr
interessanter tag wo wir
ein glaubte
lieben muss ich mir weniger um so sachen
kümmert
es läuft sehr gut die neue galerie in
new york brachte ihm schon mehrere
aufträge ein und das ist erst der anfang
[Musik]
zurück nach manhattan an die opfer ist
seit eines der wohlhabendsten viertel
new yorks in dem viele business leute
leben ihr wohnt christina groß mit ihrer
familie in einem penthouse mit dummen
die wenigsten besitzenden auto in
manhattan parken ist euro
garantiert
[Musik]
lena ist inzwischen zweieinhalb jahre
alt in ihrer familien zeit nutzen
christina und der hermann break das
angebot das new york kindern bietet
christine arbeitet nach wie vor vollzeit
als rechtsanwältin bei der credit suisse
das lincoln center ist das zuhause der
new yorker philharmoniker es ist
kindertag die renommierten musiker
stellen instrumente vor
[Musik]
es ist interessant wie liefern immer
dahin
wo in new york
das ist hierbei hatten früheren
beruf was haben sich wahrlich und
jetzt sieht man sich nie ganz im
gegenteil noch so viele sachen machen
[Applaus]
spielerisch lernen die kinder die
musikgeschichte kennen eine zeitreise
zurück zum barock die musik von johann
sebastian bach gespielt von star
violinist leonidas kavakos
[Musik]
musik geschichte kindgerecht vermittelt
und mit modernen elementen gemischt das
ist sehr amerikanisch
[Applaus]
[Musik]
chinatown
das wohnquartier von anna kissling und
über 100.000 chinesen es ist die größte
chinesische siedlung außerhalb asiens
die meisten chinesen sprechen kein
amerikanisch und verlassen diesen
stadtteil selten bis nie
vor zwei jahren schlug anna einen neuen
weg ein sie machte sich als stylistin
selbstständig
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
ihr geld verdient sie immer noch mit
styling
doch anna ist in letzter zeit bewusst
geworden dass sie mir auf
gesellschaftspolitische inhalte
fokussieren will
soziokulturelle vorteil waren mir
vorgestellt
deshalb versucht sie nun vermehrt das
was sie kann mit dem was sie will zu
verbinden
[Applaus]
stamford im bundesstaat connecticut eine
autostunde nördlich von manhattan
vor 30 jahren kam harry beutler mit nur
einem koffer nach new york heute wohnt
er an guter lage
er liebt ein leben wie er es sich in der
schweiz wohl nicht hätte leisten können
bei familie beutler gab es große
veränderungen die beiden söhne sind
ausgezogen
ich vermisse sie natürlich
glaube also macht sich weniger los als
am handy und ich glaube er
wird es machen die superleistung finden
und
der jüngste sohn hat sein studium in
meereswissenschaften abgeschlossen er
arbeitet als matrose auf einer
luxusjacht
versuchen
der ältere sohn daniel arbeitet an einer
naturwissenschaftlichen schule in
kalifornien heidi hat ihn besucht
[Musik]
ich vermisse sie sehr aber
harry und ich habe mein wunderbares
leben zusammen wir genießen es
ich vermisse sie sie sind ein großer
teil meines lebens aber ich bin
glücklich für sie
wie der vater so die söhne sie ziehen in
die welt hinaus
an den wochenenden wird es selbst in
einer stadt wie new york ein bisschen
ruhiger
[Musik]
daniela ist auf dem weg zum street food
market mittlerweile hat sie einen
mitarbeiter angestellt damit sie nicht
mehr das ganze wochenende selbst am
strand verbringen muss aber ganz können
sie es trotzdem nicht lassen
[Musik]
wie sie zu dem wunsch das brot um die
wurst um
dann von manchen sich macht doch einfach
sein wird sich ja ok hauptsache du wirst
mir ich mir eigentlich egal
trotz hilfe hat sie die
sommerwochenenden doch mehr oder weniger
hier verbraucht das ist anstrengend und
wenig familienfreundlich
ich bin froh sich zuletzt die salzstöcke
das ist einfach sie müssen
auf haben bereits haben wir überlegt wie
es weitergeht
okay kam liebe
auch der stand ist knapp kostendeckend
ob sie nächstes jahr wieder betreibt
weiß daniela noch nicht
ja
[Musik]
von new york nach zürich für die credit
suisse kommt christina immer mal wieder
in ihre alte heimat zurück hier ist sie
aufgewachsen hier hat sie studiert hier
leben ihre eltern
eine zweite heimat aber sicher wie
schweiz schluss einfach dass ich da
immer meine htc
sie genießt es zurückzukommen aber die
balance zwischen familie und job
verlangt eine gute organisation
es braucht vor allem ein gutes
beziehungsnetz werk
gleich berechtigt ist also dass er mich
unterstützt wenn ich brauch um die ich
unterstütze immer als beruft um den tag
mit all jener gleichberechtigung und ich
glaube das ist extrem wichtig für mich
wenn es geht nimmt sie lena mit diesmal
allerdings musste die kleine zu hause
bleiben
das ist für mich sehr wichtig dass sie
ältere
kultur sprach von damals und sicher dass
sie weiß dass sie schweizer in amerika
und das sieht auf dem tisch und sich
wohl fühlt
christina ist auf dem weg zur credit
suisse es wartet ein langer arbeitstag
auf sie
[Musik]
brooklyn green point
der letzte biss das sideboard ein
auftrag der new yorker galerie ist
fertig
jessicas danek hilft mit sie ist seit
acht monaten patricks neue mitarbeiterin
er darf das fotostudio eines kollegen
nebenan benutzen das gebäude wird von
der stadt subventioniert und ermöglicht
so jungen startups ein business
aufzubauen
auch fotografien rosa gesehen ist eine
bekannte von patrick
fotos zu haben ist immer gut für
mich auch live nation für die website
oder
eines buchmacher
[Musik]
an diesem sideboard hat er drei monate
gearbeitet preis 18.000 dollar das ende
eines projekts ist ein schöner moment
aber auch ein emotionaler
gesprächsstoff ist wie überall wo leute
zusammenkommen nach der
präsidentschaftswahl donald trump
was findet patrick
für mich persönlich betrifft wirtschaft
natalia doch eigentlich habe er ja
eigentlich gut wirtschaft ab ach
ja ich sehe ja nicht da eigentlich nicht
so
recht zum schluss sein
vorsichtiges erwarten aber den blick
nach vorne gerichtet auch das ist
typisch für new york die stadt ist in
ständiger bewegung das färbt auf die
bewohner ab
zu hause arbeitet anna zusammen mit
editor der rag welt an ihrem neuesten
projekt es ist ein musikvideo
in diese richtung soll so gehen die
soziologin in ihr meldet sich wieder
zurück
einfach persönlicher gründe
und das hat mir extrem gefeiert aber da
ist das jetzt das politische klima hier
mit der wahl o mat trump und um habe
bezüglich sexismus und so gegenüber
frauen was da aber es gegangen ist eine
sehr verantwortliche positionen waren
bis machen
video produktionen zu machen ist ihre
neue passion
daneben arbeitet sie im moment auch noch
an dokumentarfilm projekten und für
wohltätigkeitsorganisationen
hat es mit dieser stadt zu tun dass sie
sich immer wieder neu erfindet
sehr bewusst sachen machen die insel
bewusst schafft und das glaube ich ist
nicht macht für die jeder es ist für
extrem neugierig und positive ich glaube
immer wieder frei da er bisher mehr
neugierig das ist sie und die energie
geht ihr noch lange nicht aus im übrigen
sagt sie verändere sich gerade viel in
ihrem leben mehr preisgeben will sie
diesmal allerdings nicht
die credit suisse am zürcher paradeplatz
christina bereitet hier mit der obersten
geschäftsleitung einen wichtigen anlass
vor
und dann am ende fliegen und wieder
zurück
[Musik]
am investorentag in london informiert
die credit suisse über die neue
strategie weitere kostenreduktionen
stehen an
als rechtsanwältin arbeitet christina
oft mit ceo t shirt ihm zusammen hat
sich durch den wechsel an der spitze für
sie etwas verändert
welche sie zuständig für die
offenlegungspflicht da wo andere sich
nicht wer jetzt
auf einer persönlichen ebene klar jedes
konzern jede konzernleiter hat ihn ein
stil management stehen die
persönlichkeit und das ist für mich sehr
schön sie jetzt aus den usa und kanada
mit ihm zusammen scharfer und gerade im
zusammenhang mit umsetzung vor der
strategie sind das natürlich sehr
spannende und interessante zeit
es sind nicht nur interessant sondern
auch intensiver zu rücken die beiden
frauen werden auch heute wieder bis in
die morgenstunden arbeiten
die saison am street food market ist
zwar vorbei aber die läden will ifa
daniela das ganze jahr durch
sie holt neue bürste ab
metzger can produzierte nach wie vor
ihre service- und bratwürste
übergabe auf amerikanisch an einem
straßenrand in new jersey wartet sie auf
ihre wurst lieferung mit metzger kennen
ist sie allerdings unzufrieden
top-qualität sie immer und er bringt es
einfach nicht an und er hat auch keine
lust irgendwie mehr zeit investieren so
im sinnvoll zeitlich wenn jetzt viele
bestehen musste ich halt
noch ein paar andere umlage und das muss
jetzt gemacht
sie schrien scheiß wie die spekulationen
punkt wo ich hätte gerne auf die nächste
nächsten level
[Musik]
darwin
daniela hätte sogar schon eine
vertriebsfirma welche die ganze ostküste
beliefern würde aber mit würsten die
nicht konstant die richtige qualität
haben geht das nicht
daniela führte mit kennen schon viele
diskussionen
die letzte endete nicht gut
1550 dollar kostet diese letzte
lieferung
[Musik]
berlin nicht so fein nicht
nur geschrieben eine lade grund will ich
weiß nicht ins kurz ins nicht gut haben
es richtig label da sind die richtig war
die brüste brechen für drei wochen
dann muss daniela weiter show
und dann muss sie bald entscheiden ob
sie noch einmal energie und geld
investiert und einen neuen metzger sucht
oder ob sie das wurst business und ihren
traum nach zweieinhalb jahren aufgibt
und begräbt
in metern befindet sich immer noch das
sweet spot repair center paris uhren
werkstatt das geschäft läuft allerdings
weniger gut als auch schon
[Musik]
ich glaube
firmen anfangen soll sachen selber
machen es ist irgendwie sehr
interessiert an das servicecenter und so
dass er bevor er seine schwierige wege
zum ersatzteil
2016 hatte harry 15 bis 20 prozent
weniger umsatz
sorgen macht er sich deswegen aber noch
nicht erzählt auf seine stammkunden
ist das okay die altersvorsorge ist in
den usa anders geregelt als in der
schweiz
eine pensionskasse ist nicht
obligatorisch und die dritte säule gibt
es nicht
social security zahlt dass wir jetzt
hier ahv und aussagen einiger wurm
krachen wenn es das also mal zusammen
und mit pfeffer salz geben das gewehr
hörte sich zu unser toller monika
unterstellen muss bin ich als
fan tut
seine ehefrau heidi arbeitet immer noch
als zeichnung lehrerin was eine
zusätzliche rente einbringen wird und da
ist noch ihr haus an gute adresse in
calais tickert
die maschine ja ich glaub ich muss mir
das nicht groß zu machen
[Musik]
wilhelmsburg ist im moment die hochburg
des nachtlebens für junge
und junggebliebene
daniela und nil sind im ausgang treffen
freunde es sind patrick und seine frau
tameka
die vier haben sich durch diese sendung
kennengelernt
[Musik]
die diskussion dreht sich um die schweiz
könnten sich die partner von patrick und
daniela ein leben in der schweiz denn
vorstellen
patricks vor tamika hatte schon früher
damit geliebäugelt
das hat sich nicht wirklich verändert
ich kann es mir immer noch vorstellen am
besten wäre wohl halb halb wir arbeiten
daran
ich muss sagen ich bin eindeutig bereit
in die schweiz zu ziehen
[Musik]
ich meine wir müssen nur noch für
daniela eine arbeit finden dann lasse
ich mich pension ihre nadel in den alpen
und lebe in dieser traumhaften welt
viel goodwill für die schweiz das
ambiente ist passend sie sind im tv
drive einem der restaurants von oliver
stumm der schweizer musikproduzent lebt
seit 25 jahren hier
[Musik]
daniela lässt die frage nach der
rückkehr in die schweiz an diesem abend
keine ruhe
das turnier ist noch nicht
absehbar
[Musik]
das lässt die mini team könnte gleich
eine rückkehr in die schweiz das ist
offenbar ein thema dass daniela mit neil
noch weiter diskutieren muss
[Musik]
new yorker die er sich leisten können
fahren übers wochenende raus aus der
stadt
[Musik]
greg und christina besitzen in den
catskill wörtlich der city ein haus die
autofahrt dauert drei stunden
dafür gibt es natur pur
also es wird ein bisschen größer
kroatisches schon in luxus aber sicher
billiger aus oder esco steht weniger das
gleiche wie die machen in der schweiz
häuser in dieser gegend sind tatsächlich
noch einigermaßen erschwinglich
[Musik]
der höhepunkt für lena ist der besuch
bei den nachbarn und ihren willen
für christine und ihrer familie sind
solche tage extrem wertvolle verschnupft
die familie scheint glücklich und
zufrieden hat
sich in ihrem leben etwas verändert in
den letzten eineinhalb jahren
kommt gerade nichts ihnen sind da waren
diese wahlen
nein lassen wir das lena ist doppelt so
groß sie redet viel mehr wir messen die
veränderungen vor allem an den als
entwicklung moment
kristina hat alles was sie sich
gewünscht hat was bedeutet für sie
glücklich
macht und wo ist voll an das ist
vielleicht schwierigste
[Musik]
sie jedenfalls hat ihr glück in new york
gefunden
[Musik]
daniela ist mit neil und den kindern
leon und lily zu hause sie ist gespannt
auf die neuen würste und vergleicht sie
mit der letzten lieferung
[Musik]
jetzt ist patrick
sie sind groß schwer
und die haben sie haben einfach
manchmal macht er das extra
dir entscheidet ist
eine der letzten lieferungen war zwar
genießbar aber ihrer meinung nach
unverkäuflich deshalb hat sie sie einer
gassenküche geschenkt
3d new bag sind
sind wir
weg
[Musik]
was tun
wenn er an das garantiere dass ihr die
mir nicht leicht dass man
daniela ist unentschlossen ob sie kennen
doch nochmals zu einer weiteren
wurstproduktion überreden soll
[Musik]
an der upper east side sind die kinder
unterwegs zur schule begleitet von
müttern oder halt cool alleine mit dem
taxi
[Musik]
christina bringt lena vor der arbeit in
den vor kindergarten er ist zehn minuten
zu fuß entfernt neben der kirche der
christina angehört
mit zweieinhalb jahren in den
kindergarten ist das normal in new york
öffentlich
vor
und das ist natürlich super will jetzt
auch die möglichkeit hat das machen zu
können also nicht nur privatpersonen ali
und interessant sie widerstand dynamik
zwischen schulen und öffentlichen
schulen andere wie jetzt also auch dann
für elektromaschinenbau zugang werde sie
die öffentlich geänderten nicht viele
wohlhabende eltern stecken ihr kind
praktisch von geburt an in irgendwelche
privaten kurse ist dieser art
frühförderung für christina ein thema
ich hoffe dass sie danach
das
machen
[Musik]
die hitze war
der l3 dj zwischen burg linn in
manhattan patricks leben spielt sich vor
allem in brooklyn ab nach manhattan
kommt der höchstens ein bis zweimal die
woche
[Musik]
im centre of design gibt es auf acht
stockwerken über 100 shops für
inneneinrichtungen hier ist auch seine
neue galerie
[Musik]
vor einem jahr hat ihnen dekorateur
bradford diese galerie eröffnet und
patrick in sein team aufgenommen
patrick bespricht mit den galeristen
seine nächsten projekte
brett gestaltet eine neue wohne und
möchte den kunden ein sideboard von
patrick vorschlagen er ist fasziniert
von der präzision und ausstrahlung von
patricks designs
obwohl seine werke modernen und präzis
sind haben sie immer noch diese
seelenvolle qualität
[Musik]
patrick kreiert zwischen 20 und 30
einzelstücke im jahr und führt ein gutes
leben in new york
[Musik]
eigentlich würde ich gerne mal in die
schweiz machen wir haben wir schön bis
zurück in der schweiz machen und aber
eigentlich bin ich glücklich bin nicht
so
schlimm sagen ich soll somit rund aber
ich bin glücklich
eine lebensphilosophie die new york voll
entspricht
[Musik]
im madison square park genießen die new
yorker die winterliche sonne hier liegt
die credit suisse der arbeitsort von
christina
die anwältin gönnt sich eine seltene
pause
[Musik]
christina schätzt es dass sie eine
arbeit hat die sie erfüllt obwohl die
tage lang sind und sie wenig zeit für
sich selber hat
man
entspannen sich und annas und ich habe
zusammen gelacht und redet über den tag
und was passiert ist und das tut dann so
entspannen und kraft wieder zum
weitermachen
christina schafft es gut ihr leben zu
managen nur etwas würde sie sich
wünschen wenn sie dürfte
keine zeit mehr für solche gedanken sie
muss zurück an die arbeit
[Musik]
gegen abend verwandelt sich new york in
eine andere stadt
harry hat feierabend um noch ein date
mit seiner frau heidi seit die söhne
ausgezogen sind machen sie das öfters
grand central station der größte bahnhof
der welt jeden tag laufen hier
dreiviertel millionen menschen durch
die kommt mit dem zug von stanfords
[Gelächter]
der weg zum prix führt über die
berühmteste straßenkreuzung der welt den
times square
selbst nach 30 jahren sind die beiden
noch fasziniert
ich liebe es war oft hier bevor ich
harry traf ich liebte es immer in der
stadt zu sein jetzt wo die kinder groß
sind haben wir wieder mehr zeit zusammen
etwas in der stadt zu unternehmen
großartig
sie sehen sich ein stück von cirque du
soleil an in einem geschichtsträchtigen
theater dem zweitgrößten am broadway
[Musik]
im stadtteil buschweg leben vor allem
menschen aus lateinamerika und man hört
fast mehr spanisch als amerikanisch
daniela ist auf dem weg ins tonstudio
von ihr sie hat sich entschieden sie
will nicht mehr mit metzger kennt
zusammenarbeiten bestellt aber noch so
lange bei ihm bis sie einen neuen
gefunden hat star wars soll weitergehen
ein neues studio haben größten die bruno
mars aufgenommen
nils band spielte mit amy winehouse und
produzierte ihr album das mit mehreren
grammys ausgezeichnet worden ist
[Musik]
sharon jones die leadsängerin von nils
band ist kürzlich gestorben
das wird viel verändern
daniela und neil machen sich nun
ernsthaft gedanken wo und wie es
weitergehen soll
was passiert ist und ich bin extrem mild
war einfach von new york von der stadt
vom vom alltag vom einfach stress war
man hat wenn man in der stadt bleibt
ruhiger um mich um
daniela hatte früher oft heimweh und die
show kamenz leben vor allem wegen nils
plattenlabel und der band in new york
der tod von sharon jones stellt alles in
ein neues licht
lille hat den schweizer pass beantragt
und fände es attraktiv in der schweiz zu
leben
ein großer teil unseres geschäfts ist
der vertrieb und verkauf in europa es
gibt also viel arbeit dort ich verliere
die verbindung zur city nie wo immer ich
auch bin
[Musik]
eine rückkehr in die schweiz würde für
daniela allerdings bedeuten dass sie ihr
bratwurst business aufgeben müsste
[Applaus]
[Musik]
bei daniela und neil wird's konkret sie
suchen einen neuen ort zum leben mit
mehr lebensqualität
entweder außerhalb der stadt oder in der
schweiz
[Musik]
harry und heidi schauen sich sechs oder
jan
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
speziell für new york und nennen das
hört bisher nur
kurz fantastisch fantastisch lästig sind
schön aber sie genießen das leben hier
aber für die zukunft haben auch sie noch
einen anderen plan
so florida vielleicht nicht unbedingt am
erntedank dazu erschienen der north
carolina und der e bass werden also
herrn herrschte große schritt nachbar
das gotteshaus will
den lebensabend im süden verbringen das
machen viele new yorkerinnen und new
yorker die stadt mit ihrer
unvergleichlichen dynamik ist großartig
so lange man die nötige energie hat
[Musik]